make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so judging by the responses and how
popular that video seems to be the
answer seems to be yes
people are very much interested in me
continuing the remaster
of the uh avengers and new avengers
videos that i did back in the day here's
a cool thing
we're actually going to include stuff in
these videos that we didn't do the first
time around because they didn't really
seem to be important
only for me to turn around and realize
they were important perfect example
this story uh so this story is this is
cool right because if you guys remember
when it comes to jonathan hickman he's
all about like he'll he'll tell some
great big huge
you know like like six issue story or
one shot story or something like that
and that story will basically just be a
series of things that happen but
one thing in that story will be
incredibly important and play a role
later on down the line but what this
does here is it picks up with a
character named zhang who's not
exceedingly important right i mean i
guess a little bit important but not
exceedingly important instead
the big thing that's taking place here
is you basically have essentially these
soldiers more or less trying to break
into this facility that's zhang and
presumably iron man occupy
for whatever reason why they seem to be
up to something that they're not
supposed to be allowed to do
but the big thing that comes out of this
is is where the door initially gets
smashed down and work is being done
exceedingly fast right where things are
being done as fast as they can in order
to initiate this mission we're suddenly
met by the arrival of the future
franklin richards now here's the
important thing to understand here
franklin richards from the future will
appear again in this story and he's
probably one of the single most
important characters
or not really the most important
characters but at least in terms of the
information he offers it's probably one
of the most important characters that
we'll see
later on in in marvel but for the
collapse of the multiverse
there's not a whole lot that franklin
richards can do and in fact even if
there was anything he could do he's not
going to and we'll actually find out why
later
but the cool thing here is he basically
talks about how this machine generates
tachyons right about a thousand times
above normal and that it maintains a
class
five containment field right so
basically franklin richards has just
kind of
shown up here in the midst of everything
that's that's sort of going on and
asking the question are you guys
planning a trip and the response of iron
man and what's probably one of the
coolest iron man suits ever basically
says like hey
uh you know don't try to stop me and
what it is that i'm doing and the
response of franklin is we've known each
other for a long time and then refers to
this person as rhodey and then says like
what
you know why would i try to stop you in
the first place and so basically what's
happened here
is that this person who we can kind of
assume is james rhodes we'll find out
who it actually is later on but we can
assume it's james rhodes and as it has
in effect created a time machine that's
basically what this is
that's the question that's asked by
franklin like do you know what it is
that you've done like do you realize
what it is that you've created here and
the response is yes we know exactly what
we've done right and so the question is
asked uh do you know what the rules of
this are and the response of james is
there are no rules and that's 100
true the funny thing about this is this
is a little bit of a modification by
time travel from jonathan hickman
historically speaking at marvel comics
when it comes to when it comes to time
travel it works in the sense of branch
universe theory right so let's say for
example
that uh the captain america got his
hands on a time machine and decided to
go back into the past
and stop the moment when uh when let's
say bruce banner became the incredible
hulk bruce banner is exposed to the
gamma bomb he's exposed to the rays he
becomes the incredible hulk let's say
that like captain america showed up and
then grabbed him and just ran out of the
bomb blast radius right assuming that he
could then what that would mean is you
would have an alternate universe that
universe they're currently living in
where bruce banner never became the hulk
that now becomes an alternate reality so
that's the way that time travel always
worked in marvel it just created a whole
bunch of branch universes what hickman
did here was basically modify that and
say that seemingly there's a continuing
timeline now there's not a whole lot of
reconciliation here but it is cool
because it's basically the side either
they're going to go back in time and
modify things a bit but for the most
part everything is going to kind of stay
the same
the next thing we do is we jump to the
modern day and what this does is it
basically picks up with the avengers
more or less having a barbecue and
rightfully so right they just finished
the whole infinity event the builders
and all that kind of stuff that great
big huge conflict they
they're basically resting their souls
from war it's kind of funny because
there's this conversation you know where
where people are asking like what all do
we have you know and the response of
thor
is like well we prepared prepared steaks
and hamburgers and veggie burgers i just
want to point out that it's strange that
thor is making veggie burgers
i feel like if there's anybody on the
avengers team that would be avidly
against
vegetable-based burgers it would be thor
that would be like hi
you know veggie burgers you know a meal
for children and weaklings
i feel like that'd be the response of
thor i thought it would be like give me
meat not
fake meat not the impossible whopper you
know like that that's that's how i i'm
sorry i don't need to offend anybody i'm
just saying right like if thor rolled up
at burger king and and ordered an
impossible whopper not knowing what he
was getting he would take a bite of it
throw it on the ground and say what
devilry is this
right like i feel like that's what would
happen but it's kind of cool because you
end up having like this this kind of
conversation where captain universe
shows up right now captain universe
again you know we've talked about her
before but because of the fact that we
haven't done this in a little while i'll
do a little bit of a rehash here
captain universe is basically the name
given to a person who possesses what's
called the enigma force and the enigma
force hails from the microverse right
this itty-bitty microscopic universe
inside the main marvel universe and the
enigma force only ever really manifests
itself in times of dire need and it
bonds itself
to an individual right now once that
person's bond with the enigma force then
they're
they're christened as captain universe
in this instance it was bond to a bonded
to a woman who was basically involved in
a car wreck
and the the full-on origin of her can be
found down in the in the playlist down
in the description so you can kind of be
kept aware of what's going on but she
was basically kind of bonded with the
captain universe and this is really just
kind of jonathan hickman having her here
for the purpose of showing how drastic
things are right because it's one of
these scenarios where captain universe
is not all-encompassing it's not this
being that can basically destroy
anything it wants to in the entirety of
the universe there are beings out there
that are vastly more powerful than
captain universe right matthew malloy is
a good example the marquee of death
easily uh chaos king probably well i'd
say definitely chaos king because it was
hopping around the multiverse uh the
star brand depending on what kind of
threat they're facing off against but
that's
it's not some indestructible thing it's
more of a symbolic being
right they're like things are that bad
because the universe basically has its
own defense system in the form of
captain universe and they still can't
save anything
now again at this point they're not
fully aware of that you know we are more
or less of the audience because of the
fact that you know this story's six
years old but
it's kind of a cool thing because when
the question's asked by captain universe
do you have any pie the response of thor
is yes right we have made ready such
pastries and have done so
with vigor and then he says bring forth
the pies and here comes the incredible
hulk just bearing
trays of pies right like beer pie which
i don't even know what i don't even want
to know what that tastes like
mead pie actually i kind of want to know
what beer pie tastes like now that i
think about it but basically the
avengers are just kind of relaxing right
and they're enjoying themselves now
at this point we jump to iron man and we
jump to captain america and they're
basically talking about the avengers
machine
right the avengers program now here's
the important thing to understand and i
don't know if we fully cover this early
on in the story
the important thing about this
conversation between these two is that
at some point in the past captain
america and
iron man basically came up with the idea
of avengers world in the sense that with
the the world being the way that it is
you have all various kinds of threats
that are out there and a lot of this
seems to be based off of the events of
civil war right the 50 state initiative
all that kind of stuff those of you guys
who remember my civil war videos uh but
the idea here is they basically said
okay you know we have an avengers in the
united
states and that's fine we can face off
against various threats but what we need
are different avengers teams for various
threats because not all avengers are
needed for a particular conflict right
so
if we end up having a scenario like the
builders or something like that we want
to make sure we bring our heavy hitters
right we bring thor we bring the
incredible hulk that we bring tony stark
who's a futurist you know somebody along
those lines we want the star brand right
because the builders are a super
significant threat the same thing with
thanos right the same thing with
somebody like the marquis of death
showing up or something along those
lines but if we have a conflict where
it's just something that's relatively
small beans advanced idea mechanics
right the scientific arm of hydra if
they do something that's not a planetary
threat they kind of seem to go awry or
whatever it is and they just kind of
have to be curtailed and reminded of
their place in the bigger picture we can
send black widow and hawkeye and shang
chi
and maybe a couple other people maybe
iron fists or somebody like that we can
send them small beans because we don't
need a great big huge contingent right
it's different avengers teams that serve
different purposes
and the various avengers teams would be
placed at different locations throughout
the world hence the name avengers world
and that's why they're having this
conversation where
uh you have captain america talking
about wolverine and saying we're gonna
we're gonna move wolverine off the board
right he has too much going on and he
does at the time this story was written
uh the x-men had just come out of schism
right so you had
wolverine who broke off the x-men team
and went to go form the uh
the gene grace school of higher learning
you had cyclops who stayed after having
killed charles xavier and had the xavier
school for gifted youngsters so you
basically had
two different x-men schools you got
wolverine's time on the avengers plus
you have wolverine's own ongoing story
taking place right so it was just kind
of removing him and it's a great way for
jonathan hickman to kind of look at the
character of wolverine with everything
he's doing in marvel comics and
basically say we're taking him off the
avengers for the moment because he's
just got too much going on
and it's kind of a funny thing because
tony stark looks at captain america and
says you're thinking about this
in too rigid of a capacity it's not a
chess game right it's not my move your
move my move your move it's not
necessarily like that right this is one
of these things where it's a living
organism the teams fluctuate they change
just because we have
an avengers team on one side of the
world and an avengers team here in the
states does not mean
that roster never changes it doesn't
mean that we don't switch people off
those teams and put them into different
locations that's kind of the important
thing that's going on here right it's
these two guys creating a worldwide
avengers team with constantly moving
parts they can shift around as they need
to
based on the particular conflict now
that's one of the most important things
to come out of the story because we're
going to find out later on
this becomes a lot bigger than a
planetary avengers team but the other
part of this is that they're suddenly
met by the arrival
of this version of iron man from the
future and what of course this version
of iron man does
is really kind of hit up two things the
first is that they're a little bit off
target insofar as the
time travel they've engaged in that
they're not as far back as they're
supposed to be uh and the other thing is
that they know that because
there's a hyperion here right it's
important to say and to look at how this
is phrased
there shouldn't be a hyperion here in
mobile comics those guys who are not
familiar with this in marvel comics
hyperion is the closest
allegory marvel has to superman in dc
comics right in this
run by hickman you actually get this
amazing sort of one shot with uh with
hyperion where he basically kind of
outlines all the powers hyperion has
and what he can do and he is almost a
shot for shot remake of superman the
only person that's closer than that
is the sun god when we're basically
looking at like the bridge and the
alternate realities and so on
but this version of iron man kind of
looks around and and is a met of course
by tony stark and tony stark's like what
in the world is going on here and why do
you look like you have my armor and
basically this version of iron man
shuts down the uh the suit of tony stark
right like shuts the whole thing down
and then it's just kind of like okay
like what in the heck is happening right
tony stark's like what in the world is
going on and this version of iron man
basically says there's still time and
basically explains that a rogue planet
is headed towards earth now this seems
insignificant
insofar as saying there's a rogue planet
on its way it seems unimportant
the thing to keep in mind is this will
become incredibly important here in a
little while right probably probably in
the the next few
videos that we're going to do it's going
to become incredibly important a major
plot point right now the the other
important thing that i
feel like hickman kind of missed here is
the role of sword right the sentient
world observation and response
department
sword is basically shield except they
monitor space instead of monitoring
earth for those of you guys who are
familiar with the marvel cinematic
universe and the whole point of sword is
or at least
you know if sword had done its job like
it was supposed to it'd be aware of this
rogue planet right they'd be like hey
guys there's a planet heading towards
earth we should probably do something
about it but it seems at this point
sora does not become aware of it because
iron man basically says you guys have
about a month
before this planet gets here now this
planet is huge in size it's about the
size of earth maybe
a little bit bigger and so it's one of
these things where it's kind of like you
know you guys could destroy it but let's
see if we can't do something better but
the funny thing about this
is that that bruce banner kind of chimes
in and says here's the thing you have to
understand though right like a rogue
planet doesn't just
appear out of nowhere a rogue planet is
basically a planet that was knocked out
of its orbit by some manner and
and some means right like you've got a
solar system out there somewhere in some
part of the galaxy or even
in a wholly different galaxy outside of
ours and maybe like an asteroid or some
object of sufficient strength hits it
and knocks it out of its orbit right
then what'll happen is because planets
are rotating around their stars
at you know like half a half a million
miles per hour then if it gets hit then
it has the impact of whatever hit it
which actually speeds up how fast it's
moving and then it gets pushed you know
out in some direction and so basically
this thing was knocked out of its orbit
and it's been traveling towards earth at
500 000 miles per hour but the important
thing to understand here is that it's
doing it in a straight line and that's
what bruce banner and tony stark pick up
on right the idea is that if it's moving
in a straight line that means
somebody sent it towards earth now it
takes time for objects to travel from
like one side of the galaxy to another
and even if something's traveling at 500
000 miles per second
it's going to take light years for it to
get here and bruce banner hits up on
this idea that i mean if this thing was
shot in a straight line then it means
that thousands or millions of years ago
somebody basically sent this thing
towards our direction and so the amount
of planning that it would take
for a person to know that they would
have to knock a planet
out of orbit send it towards the earth
and that would actually collide with
earth at some point in time the
calculations would be insane it's almost
impossible
you'd have to see the future it's nuts
and then iron man kind of asks the
question
well what makes you think that it's
being sent here from like you know a few
million years ago what makes you think
that somebody didn't just you know it
was a rogue planet that was kind of
making its way somebody didn't just show
up recently and send it on a path
towards us
right this is the importance of tony
stark three-dimensional thinking by
thinking on multiple levels and
with multiple variables right now that's
that's what made tony stark such an
impactful character in marvel comics if
you're going to be a futurist you're
going to be an engineer you're going to
be the kind of person that tony stark is
you have to think on multiple levels and
in multiple dimensions in order to be
able to pull off any one particular task
right this is how his mind works
and so with the help of this future iron
man the the avengers end up constructing
this device so they basically plan to
embed inside this rogue planet and they
successfully do right you know the funny
thing is that tony stark
kind of asks this person like what are
you creating right some this this iron
man is creating something for tony stark
and won't tell them what it is and it's
kind of like you know you're gonna have
to open it at a future date uh but it's
basically a present for you right it's
something that i'm leaving behind for
you
and so with this particular device
that's basically created uh once this
devices is teleported with the help of
eden who has the ability to teleport
things across various spaces
you know including a full universal
space uh you end up having him basically
teleport this device into space the
incredible hulk jumps up
and then pushes it right like literally
where the force of its jump pushes it
directly into the path of the rogue
planet now when it lands on that rogue
planet
instead of destroying it once it's
embedded inside and the object is
activated once it's powered on what it
does is it actually
changes the phase of the object that in
a sense it's basically
just slightly out of phase with the main
universe right so and it's it's
almost intangible it's really more or
less what it means and what happens is
it allows this world to sort of pass
through or to enter into
earth's orbit right so basically the
earth and this rogue planet occupying
the same space at the same time and then
once everything is all done once the
device is set to way
to the to where it's supposed to be then
basically it allows the two worlds to
more or less occupy the same space at
the same time and more or less merry now
the reason why that matters
is explained with this future version of
iron man that when they take their
helmet off this person reveals
themselves to be the granddaughter of
tony stark it looks like you know
because of the fact that it's refer
they're referred to as as roadie it
looks like it's the actual daughter of
james rhodes or the granddaughter of
james rhodes that's not
actually the biological child of tony
stark but we can kind of assume that it
is right probably because james rhodes
died and tony stark took her to race and
basically you know raise her as his own
daughter and she came to see him as a
father that's more or less what happened
here but basically you know she kind of
explains that having these two worlds
occupy the same space at the same time
will provide an infinite amount of
energy for earth to basically do almost
anything they want to and the reason why
this was done was because this will be
important later on that where the
these uh circumstances originally played
out with the avengers and so on becoming
aware of the rogue planet
and then ultimately destroying it then
instead this will provide an energy
source that's much needed now again
we're going to find out why that matters
once we get to the whole segment about
the return of franklin richards but
basically
you know this this future version of
tony says you know it's it's important
that you
take time to celebrate what's happening
here right now that you enjoy your life
at the moment because everything is
about to get exceedingly dark
all the avengers are about to know what
you've been secretly doing
alongside the illuminati everything you
know all this time is about to run out
everything that you know is about to
completely and totally come to an
end and it is but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
i know it seems a little cloak and
dagger with a lot of a lot of lack of
explanation and you know we'll see it in
a future video but that's the way
hickman works guys that's the way that
hickman does things everything builds on
top of everything else but we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
now we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let it turn about the
it's all trees
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you